so how do you stand out in a crowded
niche or topic on youtube you know the
reality is that pretty much every not
just youtube channel category but pretty
much every industry is oversaturated
does that mean that it's too late to
start or that it's impossible to break
through the answer is no if you have
this key and that is branding and
positioning and in this episode you're
going to be learning about the power of
branding and positioning that will
result in building a raving fan base
faster than most can
how to actually position yourself so
people come to you and you don't have to
be chasing after subscribers or
followers or customers how to actually
be memorable where most people are
creating content that is forgettable how
to attract a players when you're ready
to build a team and how to actually
create a business and a youtube channel
that markets itself without you having
to sustain the momentum i know that that
seemed like a lot of promises but that
is all possible when you really dial in
your branding and your positioning and
that's what we're covering today on the
think media podcast
are you ready to start your video
podcast this year well i am so excited
then to tell you about today's episode
sponsor riverside fm riverside is the
leading podcast and video recording
platform you can use to conduct your
video podcast or interviews garyvee and
mark zuckerberg recently used riverside
to conduct their interview and it looked
so good because it's a web-based
software that records your files locally
on each device and then uploads them
automatically to the cloud using
something like zoom no matter the mic or
the camera you use it's going to reduce
the quality but what's so cool about
riverside is that it maintains the high
audio and video recording quality
because the files are uncompressed and
independent of internet connection
there's definitely a reason why over 70
000 people use riverside and if you want
to try riverside fm for free you can go
to record with think.com
welcome back to the think media podcast
my name is sean cannell and i'm super
excited whether you're listening for the
first time or whether you have been
hanging out for uh with us for weeks or
months um today's episode is super
packed and it's gonna be very worth your
time now today uh we have a guest he's
been on the show before his name is
peter voog and he
is an incredible friend
i love him because he's world class in
business but also world world-class in
family
as a father
and just has a real passion for helping
people get results
he wrote a book called six months to six
figures that has sold over 500 000
copies that's gnarly you know our book
youtube secrets has done well it's
around 80 000 copies which is remarkable
they say if you write a book that sells
5 000 copies you've you've broke most
records and so i'm like 80s pretty good
500 000 peter what the heck bro um and
he recently just released a new book
called seven rules to seven figures um
he's been recognized by entrepreneur.com
forbes and uh he's crushed it in a lot
of different industries uh rental
property he's got over 20 rental
properties uh he's he's uh roasts the
top of the industry in direct selling
and today he's really helping people on
stages he speaks on all kinds of stages
around the world um he's got an academy
and uh of course through books through
his mixtapes through his podcast he does
a lot of different things youtube as
well and so uh peter is uh just a great
person to be learning from and today
he's gonna be breaking down some of his
branding secrets
that will absolutely help
you get more results when it comes to
actually taking your youtube channel
brand your overall business brand and
your overall positioning to the next
level
[Music]
branding secrets for breaking through a
crowded industry we're back with peter
voog the author of seven rules to seven
figures we're gonna be talking about man
how do you stand out as almost every
industry every niche on youtube every
topic every category is so crowded is it
possible to really get an edge and some
powerful tips on how you can personally
stand out some questions you should be
asking and why it's so important to
build raving fans
but uh peter welcome back to the podcast
thank you for having me and i'm excited
to be here as always
man i'm so fired up to have you back on
and there's a huge question to start out
because i think people throw out you
know what's your brand or i need to
brand my youtube channel i need to brand
my business i need to build a personal
brand and then there's this idea of
positioning what's really the difference
between branding and positioning yeah
they're talked about simultaneously
where they're kind of the same but
they're not
branding and we'll kind of dive in
branding kind of tells the customer what
you do what to buy
right and positioning tells the customer
why you should buy
and what's different about your business
and makes them fall in love with the
business and the mission and the
movement not just the product so you
need both to thrive
but i've had i've done both wrong when i
was first coming up in entrepreneurship
and i feel like when i nailed those two
there's nothing that made a bigger
difference on my overall success is
branding and positioning so that's the
difference simply simply put and how did
you do them wrong when you were coming
up well first so
when i first transitioned to
entrepreneurship i wanted to be a
speaker and i wanted to get on people's
podcasts i wanted to get featured i
wanted to build my name and i wanted to
grow my following
i would reach out to everybody i'd reach
out to all the big publications i'd
reach out to all the big podcasts i
would literally sean tell people i'll
speak for free
i'd say i'll speak for free
if you give me a chance crickets
i could not get booked anywhere
once i started positioning myself got
results in the industry and did some of
the things i talked about in there
i couldn't keep people from wanting to
book me to speak so it went forbes
reached out entrepreneur magazine
reached out i got paid to speak
everywhere i went to dubai tokyo so the
difference between not understanding
positioning and understanding it is an
absolute game changer so my mistake was
i wasn't positioned i didn't think
positioning mattered i just thought
because i wanted to be an entrepreneur
and i had some content people would
reach out to me and book me on their
podcast and if i reached out they'd say
yes
but that's not the case so you have to
be well positioned you have to
understand that the number one thing is
mastering your craft you got to be good
at what you do yeah first so powerful
reading from the book here it says
branding is primarily about the image of
a business whereas positioning is
responsible for the perception of the
brand experience it involves appealing
to a target demographic on an emotional
level and claiming a reputation
or position within its respective
market so
expound on that this is really about
planting your flag maybe identifying who
else is in the market and then huge key
like sally hogshead says
different is better than better so
you're knowing who else is in the market
and then what how is it that you are
different right
it's making your business about
something
understanding at the deepest level who
your target audience is
what your target audience thinks about
when they're laying in bed at night
finishing the conversation in their head
and positioning your business around
that and being polarizing in a sense
where it makes your target audience love
you even more and pushes away people
that are not for your brand a lot of
people don't know how to do that it's
like you have to be a little bit
polarizing where you're so good at what
you do and you know exactly who your
client is
where the the person that's not your
client is going to not want to do
business with you in a good way yeah oh
this is not for me perfect thank you
that's interesting i think about in like
you know maybe personal development
business i think about you know grant
cardone people really love him or hate
him i think about dave ramsey people
love him or hate him his his views on
whether it's his values or even just his
views on don't use credit cards i think
about a lot of the people that break
through the noise uh gary vaynerchuk how
he speaks turns a lot of people off
there's no one big that's not polarizing
there's no one big that pleases
everybody so if you're getting into
branding and positioning you're trying
to please everybody you'll please nobody
and especially you won't please yourself
and that was me at the beginning i
wanted to please everybody and i wanted
everyone to promote me so i'd reach out
but once again no one responded so once
i position myself one so we could talk
about a couple ways but one
you have to have results and you have to
understand the purpose of business so
one of the biggest breakthroughs i was
at a 10 000 event in 2011 or 12
and they spent three days talking about
this one thing and i'll save you the 10
grand
they talked about the purpose of
business and i took it a step further to
realize kind of what that meant for me
and for building my business but the
whole purpose of business most don't
understand is to create raving fans
if you the more raving fans you have the
better positioned you are the more you
use the raving fans as leverage and as
testimonials the better positioned you
are so whoever has the most raving fans
usually wins and how you get raving fans
is not creating followers or supporters
because i know a lot of people on ig and
youtube that have millions of followers
but they literally aren't making any
money and they have no they're broke
so you have to understand how to turn
the followers and the supporters into
believers believers are people that know
you the real deal love what you do but
they still won't buy anything or maybe
support you until you turn them into
raving fans so turning them into
supporters to believers the only way to
turn someone into a raving fan is to get
them a result
that's it
so they lost five pounds because of you
they built a hundred new subscribers on
their youtube because of your video the
reason you have so many raving fans i'll
tell you from experience and i tell you
from knowing you and watching your
channel the main reason you guys have
millions of people that follow you is
you get people actual results
that's it
so people are just confused like how do
i position myself well you just got in
the industry you haven't mastered your
craft you have no raving fans and you're
already asking that go get some raving
fans that's where you start get really
good at what you do master your craft
and get people results and then leverage
those results as positioning that way
people come to you versus you chasing
people and there's i mean there's many
ways to do it but that's kind of it
explained yeah people can kind of
conceptualize well and of course you
know as we get more into brand new
positioning we could talk about websites
and colors uh you know and logos but
what you're saying you just cut to the
heart yeah saying that you got to master
your craft be able to really move the
needle for people and get them results
that's going to supersede whether you
have a good website or anything you use
red or blue or orange sure you know what
i mean that's that suit and that's the
harder work
but if you're able to get people results
work on mastering your craft now you
told some stories
uh some stories here of how we can learn
about branding and positioning from
brands like mcdonald's louis vuitton
louis vuitton and dominos
what's an example you said you want to
ask what do you sell
is this what the customers want and what
do you really sell which i thought was a
really powerful questions what can we
learn from uh mcdonald's so
when you ask what is mcdonald's i love
to get some comments what does
mcdonald's sell and most people they're
like fast food yeah they sell food and
some people that think they're slick
they go they sell real estate because
they buy the building they say real
estate
and although yes that's kind of accurate
they do sell food
but what they really sell is convenience
right that's what they really sell
strong so here here's an example
supersize me came out
it bashed
bashed mcdonald's for how bad it was for
you
anyone know what happened the year after
record sales
crazy so the documentary affected sales
zero so people like how is that possible
because people aren't going to
mcdonald's for the health yeah why would
it affect sales yeah they're not there
for health
if you had a documentary about how it
wasn't convenient and they turned that
convenience into longer lines and took
away more effort to get it maybe they'd
lose sales but
if they understand they sell convenience
which the ceo and the marketing team
understands that when that documentary
came out they're like whatever
it doesn't matter same does that make
sense people don't know what they really
sell if you understand what you really
sell and experience
that's a huge key so louis vuitton same
thing what do they sell belts no they
don't backpacks they don't sell
backpacks what louis vuitton really
sells is an emotional state when someone
i heard
many times from sources from articles
that louis vuitton material yeah is the
exact same as like guest or coach sure
just 40 times more expensive
right i've heard that yeah so it's like
people aren't buying because the
material is better yep they have an
emotional state they feel different when
they walk around with louis vuitton it's
this fashion symbol it's a statement in
hollywood in beverly hills malibu right
so that's what they sell is an emotional
state that's literally the only thing
they focus on so if people understood
what they sold they can market to that
demographic because it's easier to sell
a fifty thousand dollar rolex to the
right customer than a five dollar watch
to the wrong customer and most people in
the marketplace right now because it's
so crowded there's not selling to the
right people or they're under charging
because they're they're focused on the
wrong people and if you understand your
target audience and exactly what they
want
you can be at the premium of your market
wow that's so deep because think media
podcast what do you really sell or what
are people really watching your videos
for what are people really consuming
your content
for it's crazy to think uh that again
critics would say it's just a belt but
they they haven't built that company
they're they're not reaching that market
and i remember i spoke at an event here
in vegas called millionaire school and
uh the uh
the founder of the event was talking
about
she goes
louis vuitton makes me feel different
putting it on you wouldn't even i was
like i actually personally don't i'm not
one of their customers
you know but but i actually like seeing
somebody that's like man this matters
and this is a brand that there's
affinity there and she's willing to you
know really invest in that brand and and
they're reaching a market and they're
crushing it in fact i think i just saw
that there they broke records they've
been breaking records through very hard
yeah yeah because if if their belt is
400 and they make it 900
their their meaning of their product is
an emotional state yeah it's not the
price or the cost and their market is so
high dollar that it doesn't matter yeah
so it's like it doesn't matter if their
belt's 450 or 650 it's still going to
sell the same
what do you really sell i like that you
mentioned dominoes you sell they built a
billion dollar pizza empire on the back
of a powerful usp a unique selling
proposition and again where people say
well domino's doesn't have the best
pizza dominoes i could i could make
better pizza well i want to start a
business that has better pizza but you
don't understand what they really sell
and here's the usp fresh hot pizza
delivered in 30 minutes or less
guaranteed
what a sentence that if you thought
about i'm trying to stand out on youtube
and what if you delivered the same
result another channel delivers but your
videos were always under five minutes to
save people time and you made a
guarantee that i'm never gonna waste
your time or that i'm always going to
then that that becomes a usp on maybe
the same thing pizza how many pizza
places are there unlimited
right and everyone's trying to compete
but that is a very fresh then they put
the dominoes next to college campuses
on top of that yeah yeah so kids are
doing what they do and they're like oh
we need pizza we need a fat we need a
fast do you want the best of course not
no yeah so it's like i know what they
sell i need cheese i need grease but i
need it now i think the most powerful
question you can ask as a business is
like what makes you different so the
number one question that i used to think
about and obsess over that i think
people should really understand is
why should i do business with you
versus any and every other option i have
out there why should i coach with you
why should i take your school why should
i watch your stuff there's four billion
pieces of content out there why should i
watch yours
and you have to be able to answer that
tactically and results focused not be
like whoa we're ethical
yeah
usp should not include things you
already should be doing sure what i mean
so just knowing why you're different you
know what i mean we know exactly why our
academy is one of the top academies in
the world for entrepreneurs because of
our networking we know why it's
different you know what i mean i thought
about what makes the book different i
thought about all these things before
doing anything so i think if people
understood okay i have a marketing
agency what's going to make our
marketing agency different
and why should people do business with
us versus these 80 marketing agencies
that are more expensive and cheaper than
us
and then it's surveying the customer
asking them they'll tell you customers
are marketing geniuses you're not smart
the likelihood of you of someone
responding because you think they want
something is obsolete in 2021 and 2022.
so it's like
ask your customers almost everything we
do we ask our customers what they want
and we deliver
and people like how are you selling out
of your stuff you're doing this and this
we just deliver what they say they want
a lot of people just don't want to do
the due diligence i think it's just
because it's not easy that's super smart
and you know you might be watching this
and say well i don't have customers yet
and if you do you already have
subscribers you already have viewers you
already have an email list survey it's
time to do a survey ask them ask them
what they want we're we're about to do
or we probably by this time have already
sent out uh our annual survey but the
other option you have to do you can go
read other people's comments because
most of your competitors are not even
actually probably looking at their
comments you go on their channel their
videos and see what is the unmet
pain point that person saying you took
too long to get to the point i wish you
would cover this product versus this
product next and tell me inside about
this oh this is the video you should
make next they might not get around to
making that you are able to survey
actual market demand even
with people commenting on uh your
competitors videos if you're just
starting well there's a i want to get
into just a couple tactical things as we
land the plane and one of them is this
if i've mastered my craft and i'm ready
to start building my brand and i want to
get into
uh building my website figuring out the
specific branding and positioning
details you recommend a strategy of
doing your due diligence and kind of
this idea of like success leaves clues
like why go reinvent the wheel when you
could go look at uh maybe some of the
other people in your industry expand on
that yeah well i even give people
scripts on how to reach out to people
and get advice from them what they could
do better so i'm just a big fan of
of not doing like not reinventing the
wheel but more like what's already
working in your industry look at your
competitors and make things even better
the drive-through from mcdonald's came
from a from a bank
one of the managers went to a bank and i
got the bank's so convenient with the
drive-through let's use this at
mcdonald's it's the number one reason
why they succeed now is the
drive-through i i rarely ever go to a
mcdonald's and it's not a full
drive-through i don't need that myself
but people love it because they drive
through so they got their idea from an
outside perspective of another industry
so if you're thinking about what to do
think about what other industries are
doing that are relevant that could make
something easier for your customers if
you reduce pain if you reduce suffering
if you make someone feel better if you
solve a problem they care about it it's
it's the start of everything so more
than those questions sean about like how
they should start a website if they just
obsess about solving the customer's
problem everything else is secondary
because i've seen websites that aren't
amazing but they're doing millions in
sales and i've seen perfect
websites that they spend 50 grand on a
website and they have no traffic yeah so
i think it's a mix of both understanding
your brand making it about something
looking at other industries and other
people in your field that are crushing
it and taking some things you like
connecting with them asking them what
they do differently most people are
actually willing to help yeah and then
mixing that with becoming obsessed with
what the customer wants mixing those two
together so it'll form it's it'll work
itself out if you focus on the raving
fans so you could do some research and
say who are who are the top five to ten
uh successful people in your industry
maybe in an adjacent industry so it
might not be a youtube channel but maybe
it's somebody like i remember you know
nerd fitness is an interesting uh brand
they don't really they're not really
crushing on youtube but they're crushing
it as a movement and the idea was geeks
gamers
uh
and and people that are kind of in that
getting in shape and it's actually kind
of a community of people that are
sometimes out of shape and so uh like
spider-man workouts superman's workouts
different and they built this whole
and even the brand nerd fitness really
strong brand and but they weren't on
youtube really but nevertheless i was
like oh man this name this positioning
what they're doing and that was one of
the brands i studied as we were doing
our brand research so it doesn't even
have to necessarily be a youtube channel
that you're getting the insights from
and so tactically go out and look at
some businesses some brands some youtube
channels pull elements but at the end of
the day
you want to bring it back to solving
problems and you're saying if you master
your craft you get people a result then
the movement's going to take on a life
of its own and specifically you wrote
down this crazy list that says if you
can help 1 million people so here's a
test for you for your youtube channel
can you help a million people or even a
thousand true fans can you help a
thousand raving fans can you help people
feel better when they watch your videos
you wrote number two can you help if you
solve a problem what's the problem
you're solving on your youtube channel
number three
if they get educated are they learning
something from your youtube channel
number four look better this is huge on
youtube health nutrition clothing makeup
does your youtube channel fall in that
category number five feel secure
housing safety health preppers
preparedness
um number five feel positive love
happiness laughter self-confidence
number seven satisfy their
appetites food food's a massive niche on
youtube cooking channels mukbang you
know what mukbang is peter
dude mukbang's this whole niche
of people that watch other people eat
food
and like massive amounts of food it's
kind of crazy too like it'll it'll be
like like sometimes like a skinny female
eats
40 taco bell meal this is you got to
look it up see people wanting to be
entertained by that you know i mean it's
it's a whole thing and they just listen
to him chew maybe like 45 minutes they
just watch him eat through this huge
thing of spaghetti
i'm not saying you should start that i
don't know if that's a good thing we
should perpetuate but that's a real deal
satisfy their appetites uh but uh number
eight make something easier can you take
something complex make it easier number
nine enhance their dreams and inspire
hope and your guarantee man if you can
do one of those things and if you could
do it for a thousand people ten thousand
people then i guarantee you're going to
be worth millions i think it's
inevitable
that if you're solving real problems and
it's not even solving problems i want to
i want before i forget this thought i
think it could help people it's it's
solving problems but then it's
displaying the results to other people
to inspire them i remember talking to
tony horton the p90x founder
and uh they were struggling they
couldn't get off the ground they had all
these dvds they had all these products
all these services no one was buying so
they were going to shut their doors and
maybe people can relate i've been there
where i create something i create a i
create a summit or like a
an amazing program and i'm like i spent
hours and months and and so much time
and love and support and passion on this
i launch it no one buys i'm like what
the heck right that was before i
understood business and understood
marketing of the business is the key so
tony told me i was at his house in santa
monica amazing house and it's by the way
it's now the number one fitness selling
dvd of all time wow all time no one's
even close to their fitness dvds
and everyone's now has heard of p90x
i go what changed
what changed
and he said one thing one thing changed
that made everything everything blow up
a picture
before and after
he was the they were the first ever
fitness company to do before and after
picks he goes we did one before and
after pick
that's it and it blew up
that's a result result that's a
positioning and you see you see
transformation you see start people want
it yeah that's it that's how they
started everything so if your business
is crushing it if we went to your
channel how many testimonials do we see
of people talking about you it's you
could talk about yourself perfectly for
10 hours
someone could talk about you for five
minutes about you sure that's more
impactful
someone else so that's why we've really
been been focused on testimonials we
have a lot now which we're proud of but
that's just such a great positioning
tool if you aren't sure where to go with
your business just start helping people
get results and put them online people
will reach out to you that's more
important than just the branding so
that's kind of why i want to share that
because people can relate
because i've done that where i've
created something and had no i had
crickets now i realize i have to get
results you know what i mean and share
people's experience with our product
speaking of testimonials uh the book is
seven rules to seven figures and it's
been endorsed by grant cardone patrick
bett david from valuetainment who i
actually believe i think he's got the
best entrepreneur channel on on youtube
uh i mean he's one of my favorites too
yeah like uh i mean he's a little he's a
little bit bigger and he's focuses way
more on business and he's interviewing
mobsters and you're not yeah i know we
don't have the mobsters yet uh but uh
yeah he said what makes peter special is
that he's one at a young age and he will
openly share his strategies with the
world entrepreneur magazine robert
kiyosaki forbes magazine and uh the
book's already impacting a lot of people
making waves so i highly recommend
checking out the book there's more
there's a whole execution plan at the
end of every chapter and uh the branding
positioning chapter goes even deeper i
hopefully got some nuggets out of this
episode but the whole book is packed
with value so uh check out the book of
course show notes and links in uh all
the descriptions or on apple and spotify
show notes and then of course connect
with peter on the socials as well peter
vube thank you man i appreciate you
i don't know about you but i'm ready to
level up my branding and my positioning
and here's what we need to do next on
the think media podcast today first i
highly recommend checking out peter's
book what i love about it is there's no
fluff and there's execution
plans at the end of every chapter so if
you want to dig deeper on some nuanced
tactics i'm not just leveling up your
branding and your positioning but so
much valuable content that will help you
build a high profit business i
understand this new book is seven rolls
to seven figures and you may just be
getting started on your side hustle you
may be you know five figures you may be
trying to get to six or multiple six
of course when you start thinking
like a millionaire or start thinking
like a multi-million dollar business and
applying those principles it'll help you
grow faster you know what i mean that's
one of the things i learned from peter
it's like if you study billionaires and
you learn some of their lessons it'll
help you get to your next financial
target faster peter's built multiple
different businesses and he's built
teams and so i think you'll love the
contents of this book and it'll help you
move the needle especially in this one
topic of branding so check out the show
notes and uh you can pick up a copy of
that now today's comment of the week
comes from create blue skies and it says
this
love the compassion to help others
the think media team really comes across
as everyday people with genuine
dedication to help others grow in the
youtube space and really so much beyond
that
hey i really appreciate those kind words
and actually that really does summarize
my heart and our team's heart
we want you to win
look of course you know on the other
side of the camera or your headphones or
speakers you could say what are they
trying to do at think media of course
we're building a business we have books
we have an online course
we
have youtube videos that we get ads for
like of course
we make money right of course we have
things that can take you and help you at
a deeper level but our mission really is
to help you win and here's from my heart
if all you do is hang out with us on
this podcast that's free
that's gonna what what makes me happy is
when you apply the information you're
learning and you get results i think
that peter's book's gonna help you win
but if you don't wanna buy the book
don't buy the book
friend
take freaking action legitimately
because here's here's my big agenda if
you want me to just put it out here
my agenda is to guilt you into doing
business with us someday that someday
you would say
man i
freaking i've i i did what heather told
me to do on the podcast i applied some
of the videos and tips from omar on the
think media channel i've been applying
the think media episode content
and and i'm my channel's growing and i'm
making money and now i feel guilty
that i haven't done business with with
sean and with think media listen and
even if you don't that's still cool with
me i you may or may not trust me on that
but literally friend that's our agenda
listen we're good like think media
is because we've learned that your the
amount of income you make is correlated
to the amount of value you give to the
marketplace i just feel blessed by how
much we've given out our business is
incredibly healthy and so at whatever
level you want to engage with us i just
want to encourage you we want you to win
that's the mission of our company to
help 10 000 purpose-driven people to
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with online video we want to
help you win
and we have multiple different levels
you can engage with us at a free level
at a book level at our online course and
academy level come to our event growth
video live 2022 in las vegas with gary
vaynerchuk speaking and other people
speaking there's so many different
things that you can do but even if we
just hang out and you only listen to
this podcast
then that's great and even if you never
listen to this podcast again but you
apply what you learned today and you go
put it into action maybe someday this is
my goal maybe someday you'll see me at
the airport at an event and maybe we can
shake hands you just say hey listen i
got that one tactic and i applied it i
got that one tactic and i put it into
action that is my
legit mission and as we end every
podcast
we are hashtag action takers
it's time to take action what do you
need to do next not what did you learn
but what are you about to implement so
that you can go grow your channel so you
can grow your business so you can launch
your next innovative campaign so you can
redo your brand redo your positioning
whatever it is friend i hope you're
getting value and i can't wait to see
the actions
you're taking to move the needle in your
life and business and until next time
i'll see you soon on the think media
podcast did you hear that growth video
live 2022 is back in person this is your
opportunity to network with like-minded
people just like you to make friendships
to make business partnerships this is
your opportunity to get in the room you
can get your ticket now at
growethvideolive.com
going so fast so make sure you get your
ticket right now at growthvideolive.com
you